Change management.
This is the process that organizations use to make sure that changes are cost effective
that all changes are made in a controlled manner they go through a proper process.
So let's talk through that process, the change management process and the components
of that process.
But before we do, I want to briefly cover what happens if an organization doesn't
have a very good change management process or the other end of the spectrum if their
change management process is too rigorous, too arduous.
So let's think for a moment.
If an organization doesn't have a change management process, what happens?
Well changes are being made and they're not being documented.
No one's looking at what the impact of that change might be, what stakeholders might
be affected.
They're not seeking approval.
So what happens when an organization has a non-existent or inefficient change management
process?
Well the organization tends to be very reactive.
They're constantly fighting fires.
Stuff is breaking all the time and no one understands why.
Someone might have come in at midnight and made a change to the firewall, not told anyone.
Now the next morning, a large swath of the network is offline and no one can figure
out why.
So a lack of change management can very definitely lead to a very reactive environment where you
can't, you're just constantly trying to figure out why the stuff's breaking and you're
not able to get proactive, start to improve or make things better.
The other end of the spectrum is what happens if an organization's process is change management
process is too rigorous.
For even a super minor change, you have to go through 17 levels of approval in triplicate.
What happens then?
Well inevitably, if a change is too hard to make, if it's way too much paperwork to go through,
people will find ways of avoiding the process and it'll also slow the organization down,
make it so that it's too bureaucratic, too slow to get things done.
So that's kind of the challenges.
We want to find the happy middle in between them with our change management process.
It needs to be flexible and it needs to be efficient.
So now let's start to walk through the components of the change management process.
And the very first step is a change request comes in.
Where can a change request come from?
Well, all sorts of different places, I might be to say, hey, we have to install a patch
on a system, make a configuration change to a system.
We want to create a new system, we want to add some additional functionality, we want
to do any of these sorts of things.
So change requests can come from all over the organization.
The next step is to do an impact analysis.
To figure out how big of a deal is this change?
Is it a very minor change to a very low value system that can be done in just a few minutes
and not affect anyone?
Or is this like a multi-million dollar project that's going to take months and it's going
to cost millions of dollars and it can infect all sorts of different people?
Or is this like an emergency patch that we need to do because there's a zero day out
there and we have to patch these systems yesterday?
The impact analysis will identify what type of change it is, which will then drive the
rest of the process.
For very expensive, very big changes that affect a lot of people, you probably need to go
through a lot of levels of approval.
For emergency changes, you might skip a lot of those approvals to very quickly implement
the change.
So the next step of the change management process is the approval step.
This is where someone actually needs to approve the change.
And this is probably where you've heard of terms like cabs or e-cabs.
A cab is a change advisory board made up of stakeholders from all across the organization
that can provide input on whether or not this change makes sense, if it's cost effective,
how to do it in an efficient way, how to minimize impact, all these sorts of things.
And if it's a really big change, you might even escalate up to e-cap, executive change
advisory boards.
The next step is build and test.
So actually start to create whatever the change is, test to make sure the change is going
to work properly, start to create back-out plans.
So if the change doesn't go well, you can get back to it in our previous state.
Next is notification.
Notification is where you notify all the relevant stakeholders that the change is about
to occur.
That might be consumers, it might be business owners, management.
Whoever needs to know, whoever is a relevant stakeholder, you need to notify them because
you're about to actually implement the change.
The next step after implementation is validation.
And this is where you check to make sure that, okay, this change was supposed to provide
this new functionality or patch this system.
So the validation step is where you make sure that whatever the change was has actually
occurred correctly.
And this is also where you include that testing that we've talked about, regression
testing, progression testing, of course, is where you go back and make sure you haven't
broken any existing functionality.
So all this falls under validation.
And then the final step is updating your versioning, your baselines.
So we've talked about baselines, a baseline is the standard configuration for a system
of all the controls or all the configuration that should be in place.
If you've made a change to a system, you need to update that system's baseline.
You might also, this may also trigger you to go and update for certain plans like say
the DRP plan because your DRP plan is meant to recover a system.
And it obviously needs to recover the system to wherever it was right before it failed,
which means any changes you've made to the system might require an update to the DRP plan.
So there's a bunch of updating of documents that might need to occur at the end of change
management.
And there's one final piece that's not mentioned here, but it's included throughout all of these steps.
And that is documentation.
All of these steps should be documented where the change request come from.
What was the impact and results of the impact analysis?
Who approved the change?
What was actually built and tested?
Who was notified?
How was it actually implemented?
And when?
What sort of testing validation occurred?
Did it work properly?
And what updates are made to all the various documents that's necessary?
There should always be documentation.
It doesn't have to be overly, it doesn't have to be hundreds of pages.
It's going to depend on the type of change, but there should be clear documentation so
you know what has changed and when and why.
So that's the change management process.